we are back to work Templeton hello you  beautiful baby car yes I bosses brothers  are they always this friendly I can't  have my own brother ignorant to the art  of business it's embarrassing I make  sure the world loves babies more than  puppies more than kittens what's the  threat what cats don't play by rules  fade up the company's in your mashed  potato hands don't blow it just kidding  of course you will what's up this  meeting is making me uncomfortable  what do we do I'm gonna bag the tiger  [Applause]  [Music]  this is my job on the line you made a  choice to join a family we can fix this  what if you broke nothing leave it on  the cat just spoon star for spacing in  fairness sir the cat thought of it first  Oh Dody you can't kill what you can't  see  time to go mommy is a dirty liar  [Music]